fin du conseil européen pas d'accord à
londres après deux jours de discussions
mais le chef de l'état françois
mitterrand relativement optimiste lui
parle de progrès bernard darty le
président des magasins darty dixième
client de paribas inculpé pour
infraction à la législation sur les
changes ont fait du surplace dans le
procès de bruit après l'audition de
nouveaux policiers cet après midi le
président les assises des fermes des
bons points à certains d'entre eux
encore deux chevaux français dopé cela
s'est passé le mois dernier en grande
bretagne mais à messieurs bonsoir fin du
sommet européen de londres il y à un peu
plus d'une heure un sommet qui a duré
plus longtemps que prévu il faut dire
qu'il était bien difficile de trouver
des terrains d'entente
les dix chefs d'état ou de gouvernement
de la communauté européenne ce sont donc
séparé sans avoir pu se mettre d'accord
cela dit une personne ne parle des
chèques tout à l'heure dans un
conférence de presse françois mitterrand
a même estimé que ce 21e sommet
constituait un progrès est quatre points
importants à régler ce qui suppose
pardonner cette vérité de la palice que
les autres points ont été retenus et ces
points là sont loin d'être négligeables
mais insistons sur les quatre points qui
feront l'objet d'une procédure
particulière
je le dis tout de suite ce seront les
ministres des affaires étrangères ou des
relations extérieures qui se réuniront
dans les semaines qui viennent c'est à
dire en décembre pour régler ou tenter
de régler sous le couvert des chefs
d'état et des chefs de gouvernement qui
communiqueront par écrit les quatre
points suivants d'abord le problème du
lait ensuite le problème de certains
produits méditerranéens je pense en
particulier à l'huile d'olive
tout ceci pour la politique agricole
commune à quoi il faut ajouter la notion
qui restent à définir
de relations entre l'augmentation du
coût de la politique agricole et les
ressources propres
enfin quatrième point le la nature la
durée et les conditions d'une aide à la
grande bretagne
les autres points c'est à dire pour vous
qui avez suivi ces débats et leur
préparation
ce que l'on a appelé la relance qui
formaient le premier chapitre avec ses
aspects économiques sociaux techniques
régionaux et cetera tout cela a été
adopté au bénéfice d'une disposition
particulière
je me permets de souligner mais nouveaux
instruments communautaires serait doté
de 3 milliards vécu
et d'autre part un début de calendrier a
été fixé
il appartient à la communauté de montrer
dans les semaines qui viennent si elle a
envie de vivre avec l'art et françois
mitterrand en commentant cette mission
dont sont chargées les ministres des
affaires étrangères faute d'avoir pu
arriver à un accord les dix ont donc
décidé de jouer les prolongations c'est
la france qui a préféré refuser un
accord global et probablement boiteux
plutôt que de céder sur un point qui lui
paraît essentiel le revenu des
agriculteurs petits et moyens qui
auraient été probablement très touché si
elle avait accepté les propositions en
matière laitière fait par la grande
bretagne et par l'as olemps tout le
problème est maintenant de savoir si la
fermeté du président de la république
sera à terme payante la mission dont
sont chargées les dix ministres des
affaires étrangères est en effet une
importance majeure des formules qui vont
étudier et proposer au fur et à mesure
aux chefs d'état et de gouvernement
dépendra l'application des accords
signés conclu plus tôt dans d'autres
domaines
ici à londres notamment en matière de
relance économique et social après
londres
force est de constater que l'europe se
trouve dans une sorte d'impasse mais les
dix ont bien voulu montrer qu'il
laissait la porte ouverte à une
négociation et dans l'état actuel des
choses c'est déjà très important
cela dit dans certains secteurs tout
doucement quinquin cette europe et 7 se
mettre en place et particulièrement
sensible dans les domaines de
l'aéronautique de l'espace des
transports de l'énergie et de
l'informatique
leur jeu claires cette fusée qui décolle
c'est ariane fusée européenne european
wind tiers sont payés par la france
aujourd'hui tous les pays se bousculent
au portillon pour placer un satellite à
son sommet parce qu'elle marche mais il
ya quelques années quand le pari de
gagner l'indépendant spatiale été lancé
par notre code clients et partenaires
européens se comptaient sur les doigts
d'une main
pareil pour l'airbus aujourd'hui toute
l'europe y participe surtout à la
construction du petit dernier
l'a310 ici en cours d'assemblage à
toulouse n'a pas encore volé et déjà il
est largement vendus mais en 72 comme la
france et l'allemagne voulaient lancer
ce programme contre le quasi monopole
américain qui les a soutenues qui a
commandé les avions pendant les années
noires de la mise au point la corée du
sud a thaïlande mais pas l'europe
ne croyez pas que la position de la
france soit toujours la plus belle ce
mirage 2000 au décollage nous voulons le
vendre à madame gandhi dans ce marché il
a battu le jaguar franco-anglais que
l'inde souhaitait acheter initialement
ce n'est certainement pas au nom de
l'europe que la france avait torpillé ce
début de contrat les anglais nous le
rendent bien
avec la force de frappe atomique commune
que l'europe pouvait souhaiter mais que
eux ne veulent pas donc les missiles
nucléaires de ce mirage 2000 ne seront
que français l'europe de l'armement
elle n'existe pas
un autre domaine l'énergie regardez
cette centrale nucléaire française
l'allemagne a les mêmes forcément elles
sont d'origine américaine
mais l'angleterre elle a ses propres
modèles l'italie aussi à la fin des
années 60 on aurait pu imaginer une
europe de l'énergie bâti autour de leurs
atomes mais dès la crise pétrolière ce
fut le véritable sauve qui peut général
approvisionnement séparer contrats
d'état à état pour le pétrole pour
l'uranium bref absence de politique
commune quand ce n'est pas absence de
politique tout court
sous le nom du nid data c'est l'europe
de l'informatique qui fut créée il ya
quelques années mais très vite elles
coulaient sous les tirs croisés franco
britannique
on se serait cru à valmy sauf que cette
fois-ci français et anglais tirer dans
la même direction c'est à dire contre
l'europe
enfin les transports avec notre dernier
symbole le tgv français
il roulera certainement au bout du monde
avant d'atteindre un pays de l'europe
pourtant les dépenses communes de
transport il dépasse largement le budget
de l'agriculture seule europe qui
fonctionne à peu près alors voilà le
problème
ensemble les dix ce serait une véritable
force séparé nous sommes vulnérables
politiquement économiquement et
militairement finalement nous sommes
tous capables de rouler à 380 kilomètres
à l'heure
tant qu'une frontière européenne ne
stoppe pas le convoi
revenons maintenant sur une information
qui nous intéresse tous que nous soyons
locataires ou propriétaires le projet de
loi relatif à la modération des loyers
la progression de ces loyers sera
désormais limité à 80 % de la variation
d'un indice du coût de la construction
est un texte qui est à la fois rétro
actif puisqu'il prend date
à la date du 7 octobre et puis
transitoire puisque à l'échéance du 6
avril 82 il sera remplacé par des
accords de modération signé entre
représentants et propriétaires et des
locataires mais d'ores et déjà les
premiers ne sont pas contents du tout
ils'agit théoriquement
d'une limitation pour six mois il est
évident que ça va pas modifié l'attitude
et le comportement des propriétaires ou
six mois le vrai la vraie question est
ce qui inquiète ses propriétaires d'une
façon plus générale c'est la loi qui va
venir derrière et dans laquelle aurait
dû s'inscrire cette mesure et qui en est
et est équivalent à vivre à la reprendre
c'est à dire que cette loi qui pour le
moment est fait pour six mois va être
reprise dans la loi qui va suivre
et c'est cela qui inquiète beaucoup les
propriétaires parce qu'il est évident
que ça réduira la rentabilité ce comme
ça s'ajoutera une fiscalité beaucoup
plus grande il est certain qu'on va
arriver un moment où l'investissement
immobilier n'aura plus de justification
et ou peut-être même il justifiera des
désinvestissements
il y a eu des abus qui ont été repris
d'ailleurs prouvé qu'ils ont été en
justice c'est à dire ah ça c'est tout à
fait non je dis pas qu'ils le c'est
normal c'est presque inévitable
en tout cas il y en a il ya constamment
des abus dans toutes les professions
alors les abus c'est une chose ils ont
été constatés ils ont été la plupart du
temps sanctionné mais le dérapage
général des loyers ces paroles est vrai
aussi que la hausse des loyers avaient
atteint des proportions importantes
surtout dans le centre des villes où
l'on assiste depuis quelques temps à un
exode des moins aisés remplacés par ceux
qui peuvent payer
il en va de même un peu partout dans le
monde par exemple à new york ou en plein
manhattan on assiste en ce moment au
même phénomène que celui du quartier du
marais à paris harlem par exemple jusqu
alors habité par les plus défavorisés se
transforme à une vitesse grand v se
réhabilite comme on dit ça reportage
délinquance selon morris hayes avec
harlem l'un des derniers quartiers
pauvres de manière
ici par tradition s'installent des
nouveaux arrivants ceux qui viennent
tenter leur chance aujourd'hui des
latino américains
ici reviennent également ceux qui ont
échoué les perdants tous des pauvres qui
coûte cher à la ville en prestations
sociales et qui font perdre de l'argent
aux promoteurs car manhattan se repeuple
de nouveau les new york aisés veulent
vivre dans la cité
les loyers grimpent les appartements des
pauvres dans la ville c'est de la place
est de l'argent perdu pour rien que leur
attention de ceux de manhattan une cité
amiral comme elle était avant
pour les gens riches ou en tout cas de
moyens et les pauvres n'auront plus leur
place ici le maire monsieur cochet mais
un jour sur ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens n'ont pas utile on avait été
pourri si la plupart de ces maisons
appartenaient à la ville qui pendant
longtemps aider les pauvres à siemens
mais aujourd'hui la ville a décidé de
vendre une partie de ses immeubles à des
promoteurs pour ces derniers un objectif
transformer le quartier en zone
résidentielle à supposer qu'elle est
encore en vie la mairie de new york n'a
plus les moyens de se poser à ce
processus
les réductions budgétaires du président
reagan lui fournissant un alibi il n'y a
plus assez d'argent pour donner aux plus
pauvres les aides financières qui leur
permettrait de se maintenir de rester
promoteur exerce une très forte pression
pour le secteur de rendre au marché
privé et fort ils essaient de maintenir
ici au moins un équilibre entre les gens
aisés ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens
regardez un peu les pots mais c'est
difficile l'aise mais ma nous avons
c'est l'argent nous n'avons plus
d'argent nous n'avons plus assez
d'argent
et de toute façon le new york et ne
veulent pas vivre aux côtés des
minorités moins chanceuses ils en ont
peur pour que le lower east side
redevienne un quartier à la mode il faut
certes le niveau des immeubles
il faut surtout chasser ceux des anciens
habitants qui s'y accrochent pas encore
tous les moyens sont bons
wade vendu ce qu'ils vont faire en plein
hiver vont couper le chauffage
confortable il ya des incendies suspects
tous les services se répète souvent
le processus est déjà commencée pour
mener à bien leur opération de
rénovation ici on dit gentryfication
ennoblissement le promoteur utilise une
technique qui leur a déjà servi dans
d'autres quartiers de la ville
ils font d'abord venir des artistes mots
qui ne veut pas dire grand chose mais
qui donne au quartier 1ère à la mode un
style chic en quatre mois cet immeuble à
quadruples de valeur depuis qui est la
propriété d'une femme écrivain
quant à cette maison achetée 30 mille
francs il ya dix ans alors vaut
aujourd'hui 750 mille les cadres les
jeunes hommes en messieurs les
intellectuels vont bientôt arriver dans
quelques années ce quartier où il ya
quelques mois seulement personne
n'aimait pas s'aventurer ressemblera aux
autres quartiers chics de la ville
quant aux autres ceux pour qui le lower
east side est un refuge où un point de
départ ils seront partis au fond du
bronx ou de brooklyn très loin des
lumières de manhattan
mais un fort secteur sera clémente pour
les chômeurs laurent fabius l'a fait
savoir à l'instant les délais de
paiement seront plus larges quant à
l'impôt sur le revenu et la majoration
automatique pour 10% donc pour paiement
tardif sera supprimé deux congrès
aujourd'hui l'ouverture des débats du
syndicat de la magistrature nous en
parlerons demain
et puis la poursuite du 41e congrès la
cftc à lyon son président jacques
tessier a fait savoir que face au
pouvoir sa centrale observerait un
attentisme vigilant elle est plutôt
favorable à la décentralisation est
plutôt sceptique quant aux
nationalisations n'ont voulu savoir
comment se vivent et l'engagement
syndical pour un travailleur chrétiens
et pour ce faire
martine gilson et michel graf et se sont
rendus dans l'un des fiefs de la cftc le
bassin minier de lens nombreux en effet
sont les mineurs à adhérer au syndicat
13h10 dans un des puits de lens la
sortie du trou avant la course à la
lumière après victor de fond voilà
françois 48 ans marié 3 enfants
fils de mineur et mineurs depuis 34 ans
34 ans à revenir chaque jour dans cette
salle des pendus
là où les mineurs font peau neuve et
délaissent jusqu'au lendemain leurs
codes plein de poussière 34 ans sous
terre une vie taillé dans le charbon le
grisou et le militantisme à 14 ans
françois fait sa première descente au
son deux mois plus tard il fait sa
première cotisation à la cftc
pourquoi les peurs vous avez choisi la
cftc est pas et fo et la cgt
parce que je fume sera libre à politique
responsable et pour sa brave
entretiennent cette catholique
et d'après vous les autres syndicats
fonda politique pour moi physiquement
que l'union parti communiste et pour
partie sont alliés
bonsoir maintenant oui
et à droite la gauche catholique
apolitique mais à droite syndiqués tout
jeune par morales par devoir sortie de
l'ami françois pas ses fans après midi à
la cftc trésorier de section délégués du
personnel la mine le matin les réunions
l'après-midi et une femme qui elle garde
le foyer
selon la bbc
marie ben oui non parce que là les jours
suivants j'ai eu même gates ben allez
prendre le temps beaucoup à voir le
samedi et dimanche pour faire quelques
fois samedi
et puis dimanche avoir enfin dans la
semaine assez pour ainsi dire tous les
jours vous êtes dehors et elle est
dedans
oui mais depuis padoue heures seulement
pour mon bazire loisirs dont le prince
semblait samedi venant de mort pour les
mettre les autres quand même s'occuper
des autres aussi est ce qu'on pensait
d'assez d'été comme la wii peut-être
autrement dit jean marie c'est peu on y
voit vous pour la télévision qui
manifestent c'est pas c'est pas tout le
monde se porte alors apprenez pas trouvé
aussi ils sont un peu partie par son
tout cela fait depuis ou actuels d'été
pourquoi il faut de ce fait j'étais là
cet été alors comme je dis toujours que
notre année grâce à la curée - syndicat
patronal je suis pas d'accord vous aviez
dit que vous étiez à droite ça veut dire
que vous n'avez pas voté pour françois
mitterrand ouais pourquoi
ce que un peu la peur du changement et
je vois que depuis qu'un changement pour
nous mais pas tellement
il avait peur du changement aujourd'hui
il trouve que rien n'a changé
paradoxe dont souffre sans doute pas mal
de militants cftc
or justement parlant de politique
traditionnel baromètre de france soir
magazine cette fois ci ce sont les
personnalités de la majorité creuse
l'écart en tête michel rocard devant
jacques delors dans l'opposition tout le
monde perd des points simone veil valéry
giscard d'estaing jacques chaban delmas
jacques chirac et raymond barre vraiment
bardon c'était aujourd'hui la rentrée à
marseille il y a un tout petit peu plus
d'une heure
fadil en matière de rentrer car le mot
un peu galvaudé jean-michel mercurol l'a
suivi à marseille depuis sept mois on
n'a guère entendu l'ancien premier
ministre sinon pour dresser de temps en
temps un bilan négatif de la gestion
sociale à cette relative discrétion il
faut ajouter la position particulière de
raymond barre au sein de l'opposition
loin d'apparaître comme un leader il
reste seulement apparentée udf et ils
observent tout se passe comme si ils
agissaient en homme seul loin des
appareils mais toujours vigilant et
aujourd'hui sa critique s'est faite
encore plus véhémente dans le fonds même
si elle se voulait modérée dans le ton
je ne crois pas que sous couleur
d'élargir les champs de la liberté il
faille par laxisme compromettre la
sécurité des français que sous couleur
de décentralisation il faille et
favoriser le développement de féodalité
régional et vous en savez quelque chose
le souffre douleur
cassou couleurs de doter la france d'une
force de frappe industrielle
il file gravement perturbé par des
nationalisations dépourvue de fondement
économique l'activité de grandes
entreprises que sous couleur de tonte et
les puissances d'argent il faille
orienter la distribution du crédit selon
des critères politiques est brisé
l'expansion internationale de notre
système bancaire que sous couleur
d'accroître les droits des travailleurs
il faille mettre en cause la cohésion au
sein des entreprises
un nouveau président pour le conseil
régional d'aquitaine philippe madrelle
sénateur socialiste de la gironde à
l'étranger retour à londres pour vous
parler cette fois de politique à
d'ailleurs britannique mais l affaire
est importante car l'élection partielle
qui s'est joué hier modifie les données
du système politique jusque alors basé
sur le bipartisme conservateurs et
travaillistes c'est la fondatrice du
nouveau parti social-démocrate sur les
williams qui est en effet raflé la mise
cette nuit et de manière impressionnante
patricia toast porté en triomphe par ses
supporters dans une énorme bousculade
qui n'épargnera pas le caméraman charlet
williams l'enfant chéri de la politique
anglaise a gagné beaucoup plus qu'une
victoire personnelle elle qui était
auparavant travailliste a créé il ya
huit mois
avec d'autres élus un nouveau parti qui
menace de devenir grands qui menace un
demi-siècle d'alternance entre les deux
grands partis anglais les travaillistes
et les conservateurs
ce nouveau parti se veut sociale et
l'autre une voix moyens
dix chars les williams entre une droite
qui ne fait pas ses preuves et une
gauche tentés par l'extrême et cela
marche
le parti social démocrate vient de
gagner triomphalement dans un fief
conservateur depuis 1918
c'est un tremblement de terre politique
a même claironné l'un des leader du
nouveau parti
si le britannique en apparence varsovie
ouverture du sixième pilote du parti il
a semblé la diète sera appelé à voter
une loi antigrève jérusalem menachem
begin souffre d'une fracture du fémur il
a 69 ans il a déjà mis les dernières
trois accidents cardiaques mais il
poursuit ses activités à l'hôpital il a
même convoqué le conseil des ministres
de dimanche à son chevet tchad à paris
prise en charge du transport du premier
contingent sénégalais à être arrivés sur
place
n'djamena et puis pour tous ceux qui ont
été émus par le reportage de philippe
gassot nous avons diffusé hier pour ceux
qui l'on demandait que faire et selon
quelle procédure
voici donc le numéro de ccp y reverra
les dons pour jeanne de djamena ccp 11
670 57 w paris bien spécifié donc pour
jeanne de neige amène à terre des hommes
justice inculpation cet après midi d'un
dixième client de la gestion privée
paribas qu'une passion pour infraction à
la législation sur les changes se trouve
que son nom vous dira quelque chose
bernard darty le pdg des magasins darty
alors jean claude renoult envie de vous
dire darty cachent les prix hollis en
tout cas il a caché apparemment des
capitaux qui l'a transférée illégalement
alors si vous voulez si on veut
comprendre aujourd'hui cette inculpation
il faut reprendre un peu
l'histoire d'un groupe nationaliste
depuis que le gouvernement a décidé de
le nationaliser en l'occurrence paris
alors c'est une histoire en trois
épisodes premier épisode pierre moussa
parce qu'il ne veut pas que l'état
nationalise tout paribas décide de
monter une opération depuis genève pour
sauver entre guillemets ses filiales
suisses et belges les filiales suisses
et belges de paribas nous sommes la fin
septembre début octobre
l'opération réussie le gouvernement est
furieux deuxième épisode c'est la contre
offensive du gouvernement pierre moussa
en sauvant toujours entre guillemets ses
filiales suisses et belges n'a rien fait
d'illégal
alors pour se venger diront certains le
gouvernement l'occurrence laurent fabius
ministre du budget décide de faire appel
à de vieilles affaires qui remontent à
1981 deux affaires la première un trafic
d'or au profit de l'industriel pierre
latécoère pour lequel paribas transfert
et 35 mille pièces d'or au canada et une
deuxième affaire de trafic de devises et
c'est cela qui nous intéresse c'est
celle là qui nous intéresse ce soir un
trafic y avait été découvert par les
douanes en novembre 80 vous vous en
souvenez au cours d'une perquisition
dans le service de gestion privée de
paribas alors là les douaniers
découvrent la liste de plus de 400
personnes qui ont transféré illégalement
des capitaux à l'étranger et le
troisième épisode de cette histoire ce
sont à la suite de la plainte de laurent
fabius
les inculpations qui commence à être
prononcée par le juge
il y en a eu quatre i hier pour cette
affaire de devises il ya eu d'autres
aujourd'hui et parmi elles monsieur vers
l'art darty on parle surtout de lui
parce que les autres n'étaient pas
connues il ya eu un médecin et un
professeur enfin il était inconnu du
public
bernard darty lui est connu du public
deuxième feuilleton judiciaire la ferme
de breuil après les témoins vedette
billère un nouveau en vedette le présent
giresse qui a décerné des bons points
trois policiers petits et grands et qui
a tenu à préciser qu'il exclut monsieur
poniatowski de son tableau d'honneur
on s'en doutait un peu alors après ce
jour de répit et au terme de près d'un
mois de procès le point avec paul
lefebvre vient patrick à ce stade du
procès de question résume la curiosité
aussi le travail de la cour d'assises
première question est-il le crédible que
l'état major de la police judiciaire et
puis ne pas prendre au sérieux les
menaces de mort pesant sur le prince de
brouille
c'est à dire les fameux rapport au
deuxième question est il normal que ce
même état major après le meurtre cette
fois ci n'en parle pas de ces rapports
au juge d'instruction
cette double question semble définir une
attitude de la police attitude étonnante
qui provoque évidemment tous les
soupçons
c'est cela surtout qui empoisonne le
procès de brouille
alors la première question jean ducret
l'ancien patron de la police judiciaire
paris victime expiatoire répond c'est
moi qui ai fait une erreur de jugement
je n'ai pas cru à ces rapports maurice
bouvier ancien numéro 1 de la pj mais
france ajoute il arrive que la preuve
l'appréciation qui paraît bonne sur le
moment se révèle mauvaise ensuite ce
n'est pas une exclusivité de la police
c'est vrai
n'empêche que cinq ans plus tard on
trouve étrange que des menaces de mort
sur un député n'ait pas été plus
fouillés c'est vrai qu'il en arrive
beaucoup tous les jours la police
judiciaire c'est cela qui fait naître
des questions qui n'ont pour l'instant
aucune réponse
deuxième problème la non-communication
juge d'instruction après le meurtre
cette fois des indications et de
l'identité de l'informateur que tout le
monde connaît les risques monsieur
albert jean ducret s'accroche
désespérément à la notion de protection
de l'informateur ça passe mal cet homme
albert leiris prévient des menaces de
mort contre monsieur de breuil puis
pendant trois mois ne dit plus rien il
est présent à deux tentatives contre
monsieur de breuil puis après le meurtre
et en quelques heures
livre à la police les quatre hommes qui
sont actuellement dans le box la veille
de l'assassinât
albert leyris avait rencontré
l'inspecteur roue et ne lui avait rien
dit c'est tout de même étrange je ne
pensais pas
l'inspecteur roux lui-même dit je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé il n'est pas
toujours facile de comprendre pourquoi
un indicateur vous donne ces
informations en principe c'est mardi que
l'on posera toutes ces questions albert
leiris mais va-t-il répondre
et puis troisième affaire à
rebondissements mais sans suites
judiciaires la sphère des chevaux dopé
voilà maintenant que le jeu quelques
clubs britanniques ray savoir que deux
chevaux français ont été dopés hilal et
surtout verra des rames qui appartenait
à qui appartient toujours à la gac ans
et qui est entraînée par françois
matthey perrin qui avait remporté une
course importante le 17 octobre à
newmarket il était alors monté paris
saint martin
quant aux chevaux de l'écurie gallorini
aucun d'entre eux ne sera autorisé à
courir jusqu'au 4 décembre date à
laquelle les commissaires de la société
des steeple chase rendre leur verdict
définitif
cela concerne 20 chevaux puis albret ce
traitement miracle doping soit
vétérinaire même si le talent de ce
grand entraîneur n'est pas remis en
cause
on se demande aujourd'hui ce qui fait
gagner les chevaux de jean paul
gallorini
en effet depuis deux ans jean paul
gallorini est considéré comme
l'entraîneur miracle des chevaux
d'obstacles suscitant autant
l'admiration que l'envi sur les champs
de courses
il faut dire qu'il entraîne 150 chevaux
pour des casaques prestigieuse le 15
novembre il gagne quatre courses à
auteuil
au début d'été il en avait gagné 6 dans
l'après midi
comme le règlement l'exigé chaque fois
des prélèvements de salive et d'urines
sont effectuées et soumis à l'analyse de
l'ordinateur qui détectent les
substances prohibées
cet ordinateur c'est en quelque sorte un
juge de paix mercredi dernier le
communiqué de la société des steeple
chase fait éclater le scandale
suspension de licence pour l'entraîneur
jean paul gallorini pendant une durée
indéterminée des traces de buta solide
in ont été trouvés dans les prélèvements
biologiques de sept de ses chevaux
vous allez soigner les gens plein show
de jean paul gallorini celle qui les
soignent chose me suis alors dit oui
alors qu'elles sont des traitements qui
leur ont été administrés qui ont été
retrouvés ensuite dans les analyses
après les courses
personnellement je n'aurais pas
administrer deux traitements
j'ai pas un esprit de traitement au
chaud qui ont été incriminés on a
retrouvé de la fini de buta zone je ne
sais pas par quels moyens les chevaux
l'ont reçu le fait est que c'est un
médicament prohibé
mais on peut se le procurer dans
voudront des pharmacies c'est en rock
lee pratiquement vous avez des
médicaments ici qu'ils contiennent ce
produit qui est prolongée des
médicaments oui par exemple j'ai de la
la ceni l'arthritis qui contient la
chine il buta zone mais on n'administre
pas avant les courses
mais ce que les entraîneurs eux mêmes
doivent se tourner ses médicaments oui
c'est tout le problème est là justement
et ses médicaments dans des pharmacies
sur justement ces médicaments
administrés par l'entraîneur par voie
buccale pour d'un temps d'élimination
beaucoup plus long froid surtout
informer les entraîneurs de la durée des
limites d'élimination des médicaments et
ça ils ne sont pas informés
je pense que si on faisait des analyses
sur tous les chevaux d'auteuil on
retrouverait beaucoup tous vos clients
prennent beaucoup beaucoup c'est une
c'est une nécessité
quant à cheval et rennes on est obligé
de lui en administrer par enzo l'on
termine ce journal su note d'émotion
pour tous ceux qui émettent ouvrard le
célèbre comique troupier mort à l'âge de
91 ans ou rares dont personne n'oubliera
jamais le célèbre je ne suis pas bien
portant
que je me libère c'est pas rigolo entre
nous je suis d'une santé précaire
je fais un mauvais sang coule j'ai beau
vouloir me remonter je souffre de
demander côté j'ai la hantise il a vu
deux fois inquiet pas droit et le vent
froid qui se rendent depuis février 1909
et 61 ans je suis dans la 62e les
métiers le métier c'est la taille nice
michel lucas le créateur du genre au
pied attention c'est mon père qui a créé
gens pour qui le premier en 1670 c'est
julien bien pourquoi les bois debout
bien trop gros juste un homme qui
dégomme et ce à quoi mme setubal fils
nos moyens tout en braille et puis la
suite on connaît c'était un entretien
réalisé il ya dix ans lors de son
dernier passage ses adieux à la scène à
l'olympia
voilà avec alain gillot-pétré maintenant
la météo demain et du week-end car le
week end
hélas le week end sera médiocre demain
en effet des pluies assez importante sur
les littoraux de la méditerranée des
pyrénées-orientales où il neigera aux
alpes où il neigera à la corse ou
neigera pas mis pleuvra ainsi que cinq
minutes à une méditerranée je voulais
dit car ces zones de plus l'écart a
ensuite vers le sud poussé par un léger
mistral ailleurs versata giboulées avec
des passages nuageux quelques brèves
éclaircies et des averses de neige en
montagne qui n'est pas une mauvaise
chose car on manque de neige pour les
sports d'hiver
les éclaircies seront plus belle sur le
littoral de l'atlantique les vents
souffleront du nord ouest assez fort sur
la manche de bassin parisien et
jusqu'aux vosges pour dimanche et bien
c'est un temps à gilles boulet pour tout
le pays à l'exception des côtes
atlantiques où là il y aura davantage de
nuages mais les températures seront un
peu plus douce
les températures prévues pour demain
maintenant en hausse demain matin plus
de plus de jeu les ressources dans la
région de lyon et l'après midi en baisse
hélas de 5 à 11 degrés sur le continent
16 degrés à bastia sachez qu'aujourd'hui
à biarritz et à perpignan il faisait 20
degrés enfin notre éphémérides pour
terminer demain samedi 28 novembre les
joueurs de lever du coucher de soleil
levé 8h20 coucher 16h57 des jours de
plus en plus courts ça continue ce sera
donc la peine de se lever et demain la
saint jacques de la marche
voilà et puis bien née journal de ce
soir 23h
hervé claude avec très belle image du
championnat du monde de gymnastique et
puis demain les invités l'antenne dès
midi sans le photographe jacques henri
lartigue et puis serge gainsbourg
je rappelle très rapidement les deux
gros titre de cette émission pas
d'accord à londres la fin du conseil
européen françois mitterrand parle quand
même de progrès et puis l'inculpation du
pdg de darty dans la sphère paribas pour
infraction à la législation sur les
changes
bonsoir à tous à demain 20h à